[Music]
expectations always come with the
territory when you're a first round pick
and you rarely hear about the
disappointment with the guys so highly
prized but it does happen even jamarcus
russell raiders didn't set sail on him
for three seasons which might even be
less for their 2021 first-rounder watch
the play of alex leatherwood has been
highly documented not just here locally
but nationally with reports this week
that leatherwood may be shopped around
on the trade block or maybe even cut if
it comes down to it when the 53 53-man
roster is trimmed down next tuesday
whether it's tackle guard whatever vegas
wants something out of their top pick
from a year ago as josh mcdaniels
evaluated his status today
yeah alex played a lot of football
it was basically out there every day and
uh you know durable and you know our
offensive line as a whole there's
there's definitely some some good things
some things we've made progress on and
there's definitely some areas where we
can we could probably do better and
improve and
um you know that's that's what this time
of the year is for i think he knows our
system a lot more now than he did
um you know in april and that that's
true for every offensive player uh on
our team and uh you know we'll like i
said we're going to use the next few
days here to sort it out
something to keep in mind is nearly a
two million dollar cap hit if
leatherwood is traded but nearly an
eight million dollar cap hit if he is
cut nearly six million dollars in
difference between the two outcomes
sasha's like did you do that math on
your own yes i did 6 million see